we've got an update on Christian  Matheson the labor MP for the city of  Chester he says he's tended his  resignation as MP after a parliamentary  Watchdog recommended that he be  suspended from the commons for serious  sexual misconduct which he denies in a  statement he said I have today with  great sadness tendered my resignation as  Member of Parliament for the city of  Chester this follows publication of a  report which had found me guilty of  sexual misconduct and it does go on but  the latest is that Christian Matheson  labor and P for the city of Chester says  he's tended his resignation after a  parliamentary Watchdog recommended that  he be suspended for the commons for  serious sexual misconduct which he  denies